Every year,
the US Postal Service,
since on average 41 pounds of junk mail
to you to achieve that feat,
companies spin $47,000,000,000
a year to get that garbage in your
mailbox.
It's a nuisance and all that paper adds
up to 26 million trees being cut down
each year just for junk mail.
Most of it going to the landfill,
44 percent of it never even opened.
Also,
every day,
$54 billion spam emails are sent at
eight pieces of spam for every man,
woman,
and child on earth per day.
You've got mail and also everyday
telemarketers call 80 million people in
the U,
s with courtesy calls,
which is such a shamelessly ironic term
that it has all been obliterated.
The meaning of courtesy,
this is lead most people to not even
answer a number if it's not in their
contact list,
and all of this just boils down to being
unknown to you and ultimately waste her
time.
Every second you have to spend during
way mail sorting emails are screening
calls.
Luckily people like us,
I've already complained in the past and
solutions had been created for these
problems.
The problem is they aren't very well
known or advertise,
so people aren't taking advantage of
them and we're about to change that junk
mail.
Two solutions,
first DMA choice.org.
The DMA is the largest direct marketing
organization in the US and they send
most of the junk mail that you get on
this website.
You can opt out from receiving junk mail
from any and all of their advertisers.
There's a $2 processing fee,
but it'll keep you off there.
Do not contact mailing list for 10
years,
so I think it's worth it.
Second,
opt out.
Prescreened.com.
It's a free service that puts you on a
do not mail list for credit card and
insurance offers.
Okay.
Next spam email.
We're going to use DMA choice that org
for this.
Again,
on that same website,
you can also opt out from hearing from
any of their companies by email and this
will last six years and it's free.
Also,
make sure you have a gmail account which
has a great spam filter.
Okay.
Finally,
courtesy calls do not call.gov.
have you ever answered an unknown
number?
Just to hear this,
congratulations.
You've been selected to receive a free
cruise to the Bahamas.
Well,
the Federal Trade Commission has started
a do not call registry.
That makes it illegal for telemarketers
to do that to you.
It's free and it takes two minutes to
sign your number up.
It doesn't expire,
so you never have to renew this and any
telemarketer calling anyone on this list
will be fined up to $40,000.
All right,
that's it.
You can knock all this out in less than
two minutes and it will save you a ton
of time and headache in the future.
This has been a public service
announcement from coffee break and you
guys have a great week.